the following content is provided under
a creative commons license
your support will help mit
opencourseware continue to offer high
quality educational resources for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of mit courses
visit mit opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
all right let's let's start so first of
all um i hope you'll be enjoying the
class
so far and uh thank you for
filling out the survey so we got some
very
useful and interesting feedbacks
one of the feedbacks is my impression i
haven't got a chance to talk to my
co-lecturers or colleagues yet
but i read some comments you were saying
that
some of the problem sets are quite hard
right the math part may be
a bit a bit more difficult than the
lecture
so i'm thinking so this is this is
really
the application lecture and uh from now
on after three more lectures by
chumbung that will be essentially the
remainders of all
applications the original point of
having this class
is really to show you how math is
applied to show you those cases in
different markets different strategies
and in the real industry so
i'm trying to think how do i give
today's lecture with the right balance
you know this is after all the math
class should i give you more math
or should i you have you had enough math
i mean something like from the survey
you probably had enough math
so i probably want to focus a bit more
on the application side
and from the survey also seems like most
of you enjoyed
uh or wanted to listen to more on the
application side
so anyway as you've already
learned from peter's lecture
the so-called modern portfolio theory
and it's actually not that modern
anymore but
we still call it modern portfolio theory
so you probably wonder
in the real world how actually we use it
do we follow those steps do we do those
calculations
and uh so today i'd like to share with
you my uh my experience on that
both in the past a different area and
today probably more
uh focused on the on the buy side
oh come on in yeah
actually these are my colleagues from
harvard management
so so they will they will be able to ask
me
really tough questions um so
anyway um so how i'm going to start this
class
you wonder why i handed out each of you
a page
so does everyone have a blank page by
now
yeah actually uh yep so
yeah could you also pass to yeah so i
want
every one of you use that blank page
to construct a portfolio okay so you say
well i haven't done this before that's
fine
do it totally from your intuition from
your knowledge base
as of now so what i want you to do is to
write down
to break down the hundred percent of
what you want to have
in your portfolio okay you said give me
choices
no i'm not going to give you choices you
think about whatever you like to put on
wide open right and
don't even ask me the goal or the
criteria based on what you want to do
and so totally free thinking
and but i want to you do it in five
minutes so don't
overthink it and hand it back to me okay
so that's really the first part i want
to show
you intuitively how you can construct a
portfolio
okay so what what does a portfolio mean
okay
that i have to explain to you let's say
for undergraduates here so your parents
give you some allowance
you managed to save a thousand dollars
on the site you decided to
put into investments buying stocks or
whatever
or you know gambling or
buy lottery tickets whatever you can do
just break down in percentage that could
be a thousand dollar
or you could be a portfolio manager have
a hundred billions of dollars
or whatever or then and save they
raise some money start hedge fund they
may have ten thousand dollars to start
with how do you wanna
use those money on day one right just
think about
and then so while you're filling out
those pages
so please hand it back to me it's your
choice to put your name down or not
and then i will start to
assemble those ideas i'll put on
blackboard
and sometimes i may come back to ask you
a question you know why do you want to
put this so that's okay
i don't feel uh embarrassed i'm not
going to put you on the spot
but the idea is i want to use those
example right to to show you how we
actually
connect theory with uh with practice
i remember when i was a college student
i learned a lot of different stuff
but i remember one lecture so well one
teacher
told me one thing i still remember
vividly well so i want to
pass it on to you so how do we
learn something useful right you always
start with
observation
so that's kind of the physics side you
collect the data
you ask a lot of questions try to find
find out patterns then you what you do
you build models
you have a theory you try to explain
what is work working what's repeatable
what's not repeatable
right so that that's where the mass
comes in
you solve equations sometimes but in
economics
a lot of times unlike physics the
repeatable
patterns are not so obvious so what you
do after this
so you you come back
to observations again
you confirm your theory i verify your
predictions and find your error
then this feeds back to this rule
and a lot of times the verification
process
is really about understand understanding
special cases
that's why today i really want to
illustrate the portfolio theory use
a lot of special cases and uh so
can you start to hand back your
portfolio construction
right now okay so just just hand back
whatever you have
one even have one thing on the paper
that's fine
or many things on the paper or you think
as a portfolio manager or you think as a
trader or you think it's simply as a
student
as or as yourself
all right so i'm getting things back i
will start to write
on the blackboard and you can finish
what you
started
by the way that's the only slide i'm
going to use today i'm not because i
realize
if i show you a lot of slides you
probably can't keep up with me
so i'm going to write down everything
just take my time and so hopefully you
get a chance to think about questions as
well
okay i think uh is it is anyone finished
anymore okay
all right okay
okay great you guys are awesome
okay let me just have a quick look to
see if i missed
any okay wow
very interesting so i have to say so
some people have
high conviction a hundred percent in one
of those
uh
i think i'm i'm gonna i'm not gonna
reach your name so don't worry okay
okay i'm just gonna read the assets
people put on okay
so small cap equities bonds
real estate commodities those who are
there
quantitative strategies selection
strategies deep value models
food drug sector models energy
consumers smp
index etf fund government bonds
top hedge funds
so natural resources timberland
farmland
checking account stocks
cash
corporate bonds
rare coins lotteries
collectibles that's that's very unique
and apple stock google stock
gold
long-term saving annuities
yahoo morgan stanley stocks
i like that
okay family
trust okay i think that's that pretty
much covered it
okay so i would say that list
is more or less here so after we you've
done this
when you when you are doing this what
kind of questions came to your mind
anyone wants to uh yeah please
to draw in my portfolio
yeah how do you do it right really
what's the criteria
and uh so before we answer that question
how you do it how do you group
assets or exposures or strategies
or even people by traders together i
mean before we answer all those
questions
we have to ask ourselves another
question what is the goal
what is the objective right so we
understand what portfolio management is
so here in this class we are not talking
about
how to come up with a specific winning
strategy
in trading or investments but we are
talking about how to put them together
so this is what the portfolio management
is about so before we answer
how let's see why why we do it why do we
want to
have a portfolio right that's uh that's
a very
very good point so let's understand the
goals
of portfolio management
so before we understand goals of
portfolio management
let's understand your
your situations everyone's situation
so let's
so let's look at this chart so i'm going
to plot
your spending as a function of your age
so when you are age zero to
age of 100
so everyone's spending pattern is
different so i'm not going to tell you
this
is the spending pattern so obviously
when
kids are young they probably don't have
a lot of
hobbies or other tuition but they have
some basic needs so they they spend then
the spending really goes up
now your parents have to pay your
tuition or you have to borrow
loans scholarships and then you have
that's
college now you have you married you
have kids you need to buy a house buy a
car
you pay back student loans you have a
lot more spending
then you go on vacation you
buy investments you just have more
spending coming up
so but it goes to a certain point
it will taper down right so you're not
going to keep going forever so that's
your
spending curve and the other curve you
think about is what's your income
what's your earnings curve you don't you
don't earn anything when you're just
when you're just born by use earning
so this is spending
so let's call this 50.
you're earning probably typically
peaks around the age of 50. but really
depends
then you probably go down back up right
so that's your earning
and do they always match well
they don't so how do you make up the
difference
right you hope to have a fund have an
investment on the side which can
generate those cash flows
to balance your earning
versus your spending okay so that's only
one
simple way to put it so you gotta ask
you about your situation what's your
cash flow look like so then so he said
my objective is i'm gonna retire at the
age of 50
then after age of 50 i will live free i
travel around the world
now i calculate how much money i need so
that's one situation
the other situation is i want to
graduate and pay back all the student
loans in one year
right so that's probably another and
typically people have to plan this out
and if i'm managing
a university endowment so i have to
think about
what the university's operating budget
is like how much money they need every
year drawing from this fund
and then by maintaining protecting the
total fund
for basically a perpetual purpose right
ongoing
and keep growing it you you ask for more
you know contributions but at
the same time generate more return so
that's man if your pension fund
you have to think about at this what
time frame
a lot of the people the workers will
retire they will actually draw from the
pension
right and uh so every situation is very
different
i mean let me even expand it so you
think oh this is all about the
investment
no no this is not this not just about
investment
so i was a trader for a long time
at the morgan stanley and later on the
trading manager
so when i had many traders working for
me
the question i was facing is how much
money i need to
allocate to each trader let them trade
how much risk they take
right so they always said i have this
winning strategy i can make lots of
money
why don't you give me more limits no
you're not going to have all the limits
you're not going to have all the capital
we can give to you
right so i mean i'm going to explain you
have to diversify
at the same time you have to compare the
strategies
with different parameters liquidity
volatility and many other parameters
and even you don't have you even you are
not managing people let's say
i was giving this so dan save martin and
andrew
so they started hedge fund together so
each of them had a
you know great strategy dan has five
andrew has four
so they all together have 30 strategies
but so they raise certain amount of
money or they just pull together they
the savings but how do you decide which
strategy to put more money
right so on day one so those questions
are very practical so that's
all so you understand your goals that's
then you're really
a lot clearer on watch how much risk you
can take
so let's come back to that so what is
risk as peter explained in his lecture
right so risk is actually very
not very well defined so in a
modern portfolio theory we typically
talk about variance or standard
deviation of return
so today i'm going to start with that
concept
but then try to expand it beyond that so
stay with that concept for now
risk we use standard deviation for now
so so what are we trying to do
so this you're familiar with this chart
right so return
versus standard deviation standard
deviation is not going to go negative
so we stop at zero but return can go to
go below zero and i i'm going to reveal
one formula before i go into it i think
it's useful to
review what the previously you learned
so you let's say you have i'm going to
also clarify the notation as well so you
don't get confused
so let's say um
so peter mentioned the harry markowitz
uh modern portfolio theory which
won him the nobel prize in 1990
right along with sharp and uh and a few
others
so it's a very elegant piece of work
and uh so but i today i'm trying to give
you some special cases
to help you understand that uh so let's
review one of the formulas here which is
really the definition so let's say you
have a portfolio
let's call the expected return of the
portfolio
is of p
equal to
the sum a weighted sum of all the return
expected returns of each
uh asset you basically linearly i'll
allocate them
then the variance
well let's oh yeah let's just look at
the variance
sigma p squared
so these are vectors this is a matrix
the y in the sigma in the middle is a
covariance matrix
okay that's all you need to know about
the mass at this point
so i want us to go through the exercise
on that piece of paper i just collected
the back to put your
choice of investment on this chart
okay so let's start with one so what is
cash
cash cash is cash
has no standard deviation you hold cash
so it's going to be on this
axis it's positive return so that's here
so let's call this cash
where is uh let me think about another
where's the lottery
so you buy um your power
power ball right so what's lottery farm
you put let's assume you put everything
in lottery
so you're going to lose so your expected
value
is very close to lose 100
and your standard deviation is probably
very close to zero
so you'll be here so you're somewhere oh
no no it's not exactly zero so okay
fine so maybe it's somewhere here okay
so not 100 but you still have a pretty
small deviation
from getting losing all the money
what is coin flipping
so let's say you decide to put all your
money to gamble on the fair coin flip
fair coin so expected returns zero
what is the standard deviation of that
good so a hundred percent
so we we kind of got the three extreme
cases covered
okay so where's um
where's u.s government bond so let's
just call it the five year note or ten
year bond
so it should returns better than cash
with
some volatility let's call it here
what is investing in startup venture
capital fund
like
pretty up there right so you probably
get feel
very high return but you can lose all
your money so probably
somewhere here we see
buying stocks let's call it somewhere
here
last application lecture you heard about
investing in commodities right
trading gold oil so that has
higher volatility so sometimes higher
returns
so let's call this commodity
and the etfs is typically lower than
single stock volatility so
because it's unlike just like index
funds so here
are there any other choices you like to
put on this map
okay so let me just look at what you you
came up with
real estate okay real estate
i would say probably somewhere around
here
private equity
probably somewhere here
or investing in hedge funds right
somewhere so i think that's
enough example to cover so now let me
turn the table around say um
ask your question how given
this map how would you like to
pick your investments so
you learn about the portfolio theory as
a
so-called rational investor you try to
maximize your return at the same time
minimize your standard deviation right
i i i hesitate to use the term risk okay
because
as as i said we need to better define it
but let's just say
you try to minimize this but maximize
this
the vertical axis okay so let's just say
you try to find
the highest possible return for that
portfolio
with the lowest possible standard
deviation
so will you pick this one would you pick
this one
okay so then eliminate those two
but for this that's actually all
possible right
so then that's where we learned about
the efficient frontier
so what is efficient frontier it's
really the
the possible combination of those
investments
you can push out to the boundary that
you can no longer
find another combination given the same
standard deviation you no longer have
you can find a higher return so you
reach the boundary and same is true that
for the same
return you can no longer minimize
your standard deviation by finding
another combination
okay so that's called efficient frontier
how do you find the efficient frontier
right that's what
essentially those work were done and got
them nobel prize
obviously it's more than that but but
you get the flavor from
the previous lectures so what i'm going
to do today
is really reduce all these to
the special case of two assets then we
can really
derive a lot of intuition from that
so we have sigma r we're going to ignore
what's below this now right we don't
want to be there
and we want to stay on the upright so
let's consider one special case
so again for that let's write out for
the two assets
so what is r of p is w1
r1 plus y minus
w1 r2 right very simple
math and what is sigma p
so the standard deviation of the
portfolio or the variance
of that which is a square we know that's
that's for the two asset class special
case
so let me give you
further restriction which let's consider
if all 1 equal to r2 again here meaning
expected return
i'm simplifying some of the notations
and sigma 1
equal to 0
and sigma 2 not equal to zero
what is rho what is the correlation
zero right because you you have no
volatility on
okay so what is uh
so what's that it's really undefined
it's really undefined yes yeah
yeah there's no yeah that's right
okay so let's look at this uh so you
have sigma 2 here
sigma 1 is 0
and you have r1
equal to r2 what is all of p
it's all right so
because the weighting doesn't matter so
it's gonna you know it's gonna be fall
along this line so here
is when weight one equal to zero so when
you weigh
everything on the second asset here
you weigh the first asset 100
so you have a possible combination along
this line on this
flat line so very simple right so i
like to start with really a simple case
so what if
what if sigma 1
also is not 0 but
sigma y equal to sigma 2 and the further
i
impose impose the correlation to be 0.
okay what is this line look at so i have
sigma two equal to sigma one
and all one's still equal to r2 so all
p still equal to r1 or r2 right
what is this line look like
so volatility is the same return is also
the same of each of the asset
class you have two strategies or two
instruments
they are zeroly correlated
how would you how would you combine them
so you take the derivative of this
variance with regarding to the weight
right
and then you minimize that so that's
you what you find is so at this point
is r1 equal to zero
or i'm sorry w a one or w
one equal to one you're at this point
right agree so you choose either you
will be ending up the portfolio
exposure in terms of return and variance
will be right here but what if you
choose
so when you try to find the minimum
variance you actually end up i'm not
going to do the math you can do it
afterwards you check
by yourself okay you will find at this
point
that's when they are equally weighted
half and half
so you get
square root of that so you actually have
a significant
reduction of the variance of the
portfolio
by choosing half and half zero correlate
the portfolio
so what's that called what's that
benefit diversification
right when you have less than perfectly
correlated positively correlated assets
you can actually achieve the same return
but having a lower standard deviation
i'll say okay that's fairly
straightforward so let's look at a few
more special cases i want really
to have you establish this intuition
so let's think about
what if in the same example what if
rho equals to one perfectly correlated
then you can't right so you end up just
at this
one point i agree
okay
what if it's totally negatively
correlated
perfectly negatively correlated
what's this line look like
right
and
so if your weight everything to one side
you're going to still get this point
but if you wait half and half
you can achieve basically zero variance
i think we you showed that last time you
learned that last time
okay and so let's look beyond those
cases
so what now let's look at
so r1 does not equal to r2 anymore
sigma 1 equal to 0. there's no
volatility
of the first asset so that's cash okay
so that's a riskless
asset in the first one so that so let's
even call it r1
is less than or two so that's the right
you have the cash asset then you have a
non-cash asset
row equal to zero zero correlation so
let's look at what this line looks like
so r1 r2 sigma 2 here
when you when your weight
asset 2 100
you're gonna get this point right when
you weigh
asset 100
you're going to get this point right
so what's in the middle
of your return as a
function of variance can someone guess
try again yeah i know i know uh
thank you are there any other answers
okay this is actually let me just derive
very quickly for you right
sigma y equals zero rho equal to zero
what's sigma p
right and
sigma p is essentially
it's proportional to sigma two with the
weighting
okay and what's all
r is a comp linear combination of r1 and
r2
so it's still um
so it's linear
okay so because in these cases
you actually you essentially
you return is a linear function
and the slope what is what is the slope
of this
oh let's let's wait on the slope so we
can we can come back to this because
this actually relates back
to the so called the capital
market line or capital uh allocation
line
okay because last time we talked about
the efficient frontier
that's when we have no riskless assets
in in the portfolio right when you add
on cash
then you actually you can select
you can combine the cash into the
portfolio
by having a higher
higher boundary higher efficient
frontier and essentially higher return
with the same exposure
so let's look at a couple more cases
then i will
tell you um so i think
let's look at so r1
is less than all two and uh
volatilities are not zero also sigma 1
is less than sigma 2
but it has
it has a negative correlation of one so
you have
acid one asset two and as we know
when you pick half and half this goes to
zero
so this is a quadratic function you can
verify and improve it later and
what if when rho equal to 0
and uh i actually i
i what i so sigma one should be here
okay so when rho
equal to zero this no longer goes to the
variance
can no longer be minimized to zero
so this is your efficient frontier this
part
i think that's uh enough examples of two
assets
for the efficient frontier so you get
the idea so then
what if we have three assets right so
let me just touch upon that
very quickly if you have one more asset
here
essentially you can you can solve the
same equations
and uh you when the stream
uh special case i can you can
verify afterwards you know all the
volatilities are equal and the
zero correlation among the assets
you're going to be able to minimize
sigma p
equal to 1 over the square root of 3
of sigma 1. okay
so it seems pretty neat right the math
is not hard
and straightforward but it gives you the
idea
how to answer your question how to
select them when you have
you start with two right so why two
assets are so important
what's what's the implication in
practice it's actually
it's a very popular combination
a lot of the asset managers they simply
benchmark to
bonds versus equity and one famous
combination is really 60 40
they call it 60 40 combination 60 in
equity 14
bonds and even nowadays any fund manager
you have that people still ask you to
compare your performance with that
combination so
the two asset examples seem to be
quite easy and simple but actually it's
uh
it's a very um important one to uh to
compare
and that will lead me to get into the uh
risk parity uh discussion but before i
get to risk parity
discussion i want to reveal the concept
of
beta and sharp ratio
so
so that's a so your portfolio return
uh you this is your benchmark uh return
of m expected return this is the rf is
the
risk free uh return so essentially your
cache return
and the alpha is what you can generate
addition uh
additionally so let's even not to worry
about this uh
small other terms or not necessarily
small but the
for the simplicity i'll just reveal that
so
that's your beta what is your sharp
ratio
okay and and you can you can
so sometimes shop ratio is also called
risk weighted uh risk-weighted return or
risk adjusted return okay
and how many of you have heard the
kelly's
formula so kelly's formula basically
uh gives you that when you have let's
say
in the in the gambling example you know
your
winning probability is p
so how this basically tells you how much
to size up how much you want to bet on
so it's very simple
formula
so if you have a winning probability
of 50 50 how much you're bet on
nothing so if you have p equal to 100
you you you bet 100 of your position
if you have a winning probability of
negative 100 percent
so that what does it mean that means
your 100 probability of losing it
what do you do you bet the other way
around
right you bet the other side so when p
equal to negative
uh i'm sorry actually i said
when p equal to zero you losing
probability becomes a hundred percent
right so you bet 100 the other way okay
so that uh i leave to you to think about
you know that's when
you have discrete outcome case and
but when you construct a portfolio this
leads to the next question is
in addition to the efficient frontier
discussion
is that really all about asset
allocation is that how we
calculate our weights of each asset or
strategy to choose from
the end the answer is no right so let's
look at the
60 40 portfolio example
so again two assets stock
stock has let's say 60 percent
40 percent
bonds
so on this
so typically your scot is i mean
stock volatility is higher than the
bonds and the return is
expected return is also higher so your
60 40 combinations likely
fall on this uh on the higher return and
a higher
uh standard deviation part of the of the
efficient frontier so the question was
so that's typically people do before
2000 you know
a real asset manager uh the easiest way
or the passive way
just to allocate 60 40.
but after 2000 what happened was
you know when after the equity market
peaked
and the bond had a huge rally right as
uh
you know first you know greenspan cut
interest rate
and uh um before the y2k
uh in the year 2000 you think it's kind
of funny
at that time everybody worried about the
year 2000
coming up all the computers gonna stop
working
because all the software were not
prepared
for crossing this millennium event so
they had to cut the interest rate for
this event but actually nothing happened
so everything was okay but then left the
market was plenty of cash
and also after the tech bubble uh
bursted
so that was a good portfolio but then
obviously in 2008 when the equity market
crashed
the bond market the government bond high
grade market had a huge rally
and so that made people question
that is this 60 40 allocation
of asset simply by the market value
the optimal way of doing it even though
you're falling on
the efficient frontier but how do you
compare
different points is that simple choice
of your
objectives your situation or there's
actually
another ways to other ways to optimize
it
so that's where the risk parity concept
was really the concept has been around
but the term
was really coined uh in 2005
so quite recently by by a guy named
edward chen
he basically said okay instead of
allocating 60 40 based on market value
why why shouldn't we consider allocating
risk
instead of a targeting return targeting
asset amount
let's target let's think about a case
where we can have equal weighting of
risk
between the two assets so risk parity
really means
equal risk weighting rather than call a
market exposure and
then the further step
he took was he said okay so this
actually okay it's equal risk so you
have lower
return and the lower risk a lower
standard deviation but
sometimes people really want a higher
return right how do you how do you
satisfy both
you know higher return and lower risk is
there a free lunch
so he was thinking right so there is
actually it's not not quite free but
it's
the closest thing you probably heard
this phrase many times the closest thing
in investment
of free lunch is
diversification okay
and so he's he's using a leverage here
as well so
but let me talk about a bit more about
diversification give you a couple of
more examples
okay that that phrase
about the the free lunch and the
diversification was actually
from uh is that from markowitz or
people gave him that term
okay but anyway so so let me give you
another
simple example okay so let's consider
uh two asset a
and b in year one
a goes up to on
basically doubles and the year two
goes down fifty percent so where does it
end up
so start with 100 it goes up
to 200 then you
you go down 50 on the new base
so it returns nothing right it comes
back so
asset b in year one loses fifty percent
then doubles up hundred percent in the
year two
so asset b
it basically goes down to 50
and it goes back up to 100
so that's when you look at them
independently
but if what if you had a 50 50 weight of
the two assets
so someone is quick on mass can tell me
what what does it change
so a goes up like that b
goes down like that now you have a 50
50.
a and b so let's look at magic so
in year one
a you have only 50 percent
so it goes up a hundred percent
so that's up 50 on the total basis
b you also weight 50
but it goes down 50
so you you have lost 25 percent
so at the end of the year one you
actually
so this is a combined 50
50 portfolio year one and year two so
you start with one 100
you're up uh to 1.25
at this point okay so
at the end of year one you rebalance
right so you you have to come back to 50
50.
so what do you do so this becomes
75 right so you no longer have the 50 50
weight equal so you have to sell a to
come back to
50 and buy use the money to buy b
so you have new 50 50 uh
weight asset again
you can figure out the mass but what
what it happens
in the following year when you have this
move this comes back 50 this goes up 100
you return another 25
positively
without the volatility
so you have a straight line you can keep
so
this two-year is a so that's so-called
diversification benefit and in the 60 40
bond market
that's really the idea people think
about uh how to
you know combine them and uh
so let me talk a little bit about risk
parity and how you actually achieve them
i try to leave plenty of time for
four questions
so that's the return and so let's
let's forget about these
so let's leave cash here okay so the
previous example i gave you
when you have two assets
one is cash r1
the other is not the other has a
volatility
sigma 2
you have this point right so and i said
what's in between is a straight line
that's your
asset allocation different combination
did it occur to you why can't we go
beyond this point
so this point is when we wait
w2 equal to one that'll be one equal to
zero
right that's when you weight everything
into this asset two
but what if you go beyond that what does
that mean so okay
so let's say can we have w one
equal to minus one w two
equal to plus two
so they still add up to a hundred
percent
but what's negative one mean
borrow right so you you went short cash
a hundred percent you borrow money you
borrowed
a hundred percent of cash then put into
to buy
equity or whatever risky assets here so
you have plus
two minus one what is the return look
like
when you when you do this so
rp equal to w1
r1 plus w2
r2
so minus r1 plus
2r2 that's your return it's
it's this point here what's your
variance look like or standard deviation
look like
as as we did before right so sigma p
simply equal to w two sigma two
so in this case is two sigma two so
you're two times
more risky two times as risky as
the asset too
so this introduces the concept of
leverage
whenever you go short you introduce
leverage
you actually on your balance sheet you
have you have two times of asset too
you're also sure uh one of the other
instrument
right so that's your that's your
liability so your net is still one
um so what this
risk parity says is okay
so we can target on the equal risk
weighting which will give you some
around let's call it 25
bonds 75 25 equity
75 of fixed income so
or in other words 25 of stocks 75
percent of bonds
so you have lower return but if you
leverage it
up
you'll actually have
higher return higher expected
return given the same amount of
standard deviation you achieved by
leveraging up obviously
you leverage up right that's other
implication of that
we haven't talked about the liquidity
risk but that's a
that's a different topic so
what's your shop ratio look like for
for risk parity portfolio
so you essentially maximize
the sharp ratio or risk adjusted return
by achieving the risk parity portfolio
so 60 40 is here you actually maximize
that
and this
does leverage matter when you leverage
up the shop ratio change or not
so let's look at that that straight line
this example okay
so we we said sharp ratio equal to
right
so all p
what is sigma p it's 2 sigma 2 right
when you leverage up
so this equals to r2
minus r1
divided by sigma 2.
so that's the same as your at this point
so that's essentially the slope of the
the whole line
it doesn't change okay so
now you can see the connection right
between the slope
of this curve and the sharp ratio
and how that links back to beta
so let me ask you another question when
a
when a portfolio is when the portfolio
has higher standard deviation of sigma p
will beta to specific assets increase or
decrease
so how what's the relationship
intuitively between beta so let's say
look at the 60 40 example okay your
portfolio
you have stocks you have bonds in it so
i'm asking you
what is really the beta of this 60 40
portfolio
to the equity market when equity market
becomes
when the portfolio becomes more volatile
is your beta increase increasing or
decreasing
so you can derive that i'm i'm going to
tell you the result
but i'm not going to do the math here so
beta
equals to you can in this special case
is sigma p over sigma 2.
okay i i
all right so so much for for all these i
mean it sounds like
everything is uh nicely solved and uh
so coming back to the real world and let
me bring you back okay
so are we all set for portfolio
management you know we can program
make a robot to do this why do we need
all these guys
work on the portfolio management
all right so oh why do we need any
anybody to uh
you know to to
to manage a hedge fund you can just give
money right so why do you need somebody
anybody to put together so before i
answer this question let me show you a
video
foreign
okay um
anyone heard about the london
millennium bridge so it was bridge built
around that time and thought it
it had the latest technology and uh
would really perfectly absorb you know
you heard about
soldiers marching across bridge and
crush the bridge
when everybody is walking in sync your
force gets
you know synchronized then the bridge
was not designed to take that
synchronize the force so the bridge
clasp collapsed in the past
so when they designed this they took all
that into four into account
but what they haven't taken to what they
hadn't taken into account was
the the support of that is actually so
they allow the horizontal move
to take uh take that tension
away but the problem is when everybody
sees
more people walking in sync
then the whole bridge start to swell
right then the only way to keep a
balance for you standing on the bridge
is to walk in sync with other people
so that's that's a survival instinct
and so that i got this i mean that's
actually my friend
the fidelity ran chan dr rain champ
brought this up to me he said
oh you're doing how do you how do you
think about the portfolio risk
right this is what happened in the
financial
market in 2008 when you think you got
everything figured out
you have the optimal strategy when
everybody starts to
implement the same optimal strategy
for your own as individual the whole
system
is actually not optimized it's actually
in danger
let me show you another one
okay these are metronomes right so
you can start anywhere you like
are they in sync
not yet
what is he doing
you just have to listen you only have to
listen to it you don't have to see it
so what's going on here this is not the
metronomes don't have brains
right they don't really follow the hurt
why
why are they synchronizing
okay if you if you're expecting they are
getting out of sync
it's not gonna happen okay so i'm gonna
stop right here okay
you can try as many uh
how do i get out of this
okay so you can try you can look at i
mean this
i mean there's actually a book uh
written on this as well so but uh
uh the phenomena here is not nothing new
but
what when he did this what did he what's
that what's that mean
when he actually raised that thing on
the plate and
put on a coke cans
what happened why why why is that is so
significant
they are connected right so they are
interconnected
before they are individuals now they are
connected
and uh why did i show you the london
bridge
and and this at the same time what's
what this to do with portfolio
management
what's this to do with portfolio
management
a different um if everybody is doing
something different you can maximize
right very well set so
if you're looking for this stationary
best way of
optimizing your portfolio chances are
everybody else is going to figure out
the same thing and eventually you end up
in this situation that you actually get
killed
okay so um that's the
that's the that's the thing the last
thing what you learned today
once you walk away with this okay today
is not what i want you to know that
all the problems are solved
right so you say oh the problem solved
nobel prizes were given
so let's just program them no
you actually it's a dynamic situation
you you have to
so that makes the problem interesting
right as a younger generation you're
coming to the field
the excitement is there are still a lot
of interesting problems out there
unsolved you can you can you can beat
the others already in the field
and and so that's one takeaway and
what other takeaways you think by
by listening to all these
that basically is a free lunch yeah so
not so free right in the end
it's free to a certain extent but uh but
it's something you know it's better than
not
diversified but you it depends on how
you do it but there is
a way you can optimize and
so it's i want to leave with you i
actually want to finish a few minutes
earlier so that
you can ask me questions uh you can ask
you know probably better to have this uh
open discussion and so i want you to
walk away to to
to really keep in mind is in the field
of finance
and uh particularly in the quantitative
finance
it's not mechanical it's not like
solving physics
problems it's not like you get
everything's figured out it becomes
predictable
right so the the level of predictability
is actually very much linked to a lot of
other things
felix you solve newton's equations you
have a controlled environment
and you know what you're getting in the
outcome but here
you when you participate in the market
you are changing the market
you're adding on other factors into it
so
think more from a broader scope point of
view rather than
just solve the mathematics that's why i
come back to the origin of
if you walk away from this lecture you
remember what i
said at the very beginning solving
problems is about
observe collecting data building models
then verify and observe again okay
so then with that i end right here so
questions
yeah yeah just stick the question so
does that
does this have anything to do with like
uh it kind of sounds like game theory
i'm not exactly too sure because you
have like a huge population and you
have no stable really like no stable
equilibrium
does it have anything to do with game
theory chance it has a lot to do with
game theory
but not only to game theory right so
game theory you have pretty well-defined
set of rules then two people play chess
against each other
that's where computer actually can
become smarter
right so in this market situation you
have so many people
participating with not without
clearly defined rules there are some
rules but not not always clearly defined
and so it's much more complex
game theory and but uh but he's part of
it
yeah then yeah can you talk maybe about
why some of the risk parity portfolios
did so poorly in may and june
when the rates started to rise and what
about their portfolio
good question right so as you can see
here
what the risk parity approach
does is essentially to weight
more on the lower volatility asset in
this case
the question is how do you know which
asset has low volatility right so you
look at historical
data which you conclude
bonds have the lower volatility so you
overweight bonds
that's the essence of them right so then
when bonds
start to sell off after bernanke
fed chairman bernanke said he's going to
taper quantitative easing
it's a bond from a very low high yield
a very low yield level the yield went
much higher interest rate when higher
bonds got sold off so
so this could this portfolio did poorly
so now the question is so
does that prove uh risk parity approach
wrong or does it prove right that's the
financial crisis of 2008 proved the risk
parity approach
a superior approach or does the jew may
experience
prove this as a you know less
uh less favorite approach what what does
it tell us
i mean think about it right so it it
really
is inconclusive so you you observe
you extrapolate from your historical
data but
what you really what you are really
doing is you try to forecast
volatility forecast return
forecast correlation all based on
historical data
it's like if a lot of people use that
example it's like driving
by looking at the the rear view mirror
that's the only thing you look at you
don't know what's going
to happen in front of you yeah you have
another question
like do you find that people are still
playing similarly like
strategy with portfolio
very much that's very much true why
right so you said
people should be smarter than that it's
very difficult
to discover new asset classes it's also
very difficult
to discover to invent new strategies and
which you have a better winning
probability
the other risk the other very
interesting phenomena is
most of the traders and the portfolio
managers the investors
they are career investors meaning
just like i'm if i'm the baseball coach
i'm hired
to coach a baseball team
my performance is really measured
against the other teams
when i win or lose right a portfolio
manager or
investor is also measured against the
peers
so the safest way for them to do is to
to benchmark to index to the herd
so there's very little incentive for
them to
get out of the the crowd because if they
are wrong
they get killed first they lose their
jobs so
the tendency is to stay with the crowd
it's for survival instinct is again not
the other example
it's actually the optimal strategy for
individual
uh portfolio manager is really to do the
same thing as other people are doing
because your your stay with the force
you said even though we have all these
jobs
in the end it's not just that we could
leave it to the computers
we need managers so i mean what
different are the managers doing
can you can you try to answer that
question yourself what's what's the
difference between human and the
computer
that's really right what can human add
value
to what computer can do
the market factors and then news and
what's going on
so taking more information processing
information make a judgment on more
holistic
approach so
it's interesting question i have to say
that
computers are beating human humans in
many different
ways can computer ever get to to the
to the point actually beating human
investment
i can't say confidently tell you that
it's not going to happen it may happen
so i don't know
any other questions i yeah
there is more to management than just um
investing
i think managers also have like key
roles in
huma um in their hr
key roles in just like managing people
and ensuring that they're maximizing
their
talents not just like not just oh how
much money did you make but
i mean are you moving forward in your
career while you're there
so i think management has a role to play
in that as well not just investment
yep i think that's uh that's a good
point yeah
all right so it's oh sure jesse what is
your portfolio breakdown
that is my personal portfolio well i i'm
actually very conservative at this point
because if you look at my curve of those
spending and the earning curve
i'm basically i'm trying to protect
principles rather than try to maximize
return at this point so
i would i would be sliding down more
towards
this this part rather than try to go to
this corner
so i haven't really talked much about
risk what is risk
right so i talk about volatility or
standard deviation
but as we all know that as peter
mentioned last time as well there are
many other ways
to look at risk value at risk
or a half distribution or truncated
distribution
or simply maximum loss you can afford to
take
right and
so but looking at a standard deviation
of volatility is an elegant way you can
see we can
we can i can really show you you know
very simple math
about how the concept actually plays out
but in the end actually volatility is
really not the best measure in my view
of risk why let me give you uh
another simple example before we we
leave so
so you let's say you have this is over
time
this is your accumula accumulatively
return or your dollar amount
so you start from here if you
go flat then
does anyone like to have this kind of
performance
right of course right this is very nice
you keep going up you never go down
but what's the volatility of that
of that the volatility is probably not
low
right and uh then you know
on the other hand you could have
you know what i'm trying to say
when you look at expected return
matching expected return
and the volatility
uh you you can still
really not selecting the best
combination because what you really
should care
about is not just your volatility
and again bear in mind all the
discussion about the modern portfolio
theories based on one key assumption
here
is about gaussian distribution okay
normal distribution you the two
parameters
mean and the standard deviation
categorize the distribution
but in reality you have you know many
other sets
of distributions and uh so
it's a it's a it is a concept still for
a lot of discussion and the debate
but uh but i want to leave that with you
as well
yeah just going back to the same
question about
these guys asking about management and
how do that they add value
i think the people who added value into
there were some people who added a
tremendous amount of value in the
financial crisis
and they were doing the same mathematics
but the difference was that their
expected return of various assets was
different from the entire
the broad market so if you can just
know what expected return is that
probably that is the only answer to the
whole
portfolio management theory yes if you
can
forecast expected return then
that's yeah then you know the game you
solved yeah you solved the big part of
the past
puzzle yeah and what management does is
how good it can do
the expected return full stop nothing
more
yeah i i disagree on that that's the
only
thing because given two managers they
have the same
expected return but you can still
further differentiate them
right so that's yeah and that's where
all this discussion is about
yeah but yes yes expected return will
drive a lot of these decisions
if you know one manager is good you
expect a return
three years later he's gonna make uh 150
you don't really care what's in between
right you're just going to write it
write it through
but if you but the problem is you don't
know for sure
yeah you will never be sure yeah
i like that sure
looked at in simplified settings
estimating returns and volatilities
and the problem uh
the conclusion from the problem was you
basically cannot
estimate returns very well even with
more data
over an historical period but you can
estimate volatility much better with
more data
so there's really an issue of perhaps
luck in getting the return
estimates right with different managers
which are
hard to prove that there was really
expertise behind that
although with volatility uh you really
can
have improved estimates and i think
possibly the risk parity portfolio
those portfolios are focusing not on
return expectations but
saying we're going to consider different
choices based just on how much risk
that they have yeah and equalize that
risk and
the expected return you know we should
be comparable across those perhaps
yeah so that's yeah so that highlights
the difficulty of forecasting return
forecasting volatility forecasting
correlation
so risk parity appears to be another
elegant way of
proposing optimal strategy but it has
the same problems
yeah actually i also want to highlight
now you mentioned the kelly criterion
yeah
which uh we haven't covered the theory
for that okay previously but i encourage
people to look into that
it deals with issues of sort of
multi-period investments
as opposed to single period investments
and most
all this classical theory we've been
discussing uh
that i discussed uh covers just a single
period analysis which is
an oversimplification of investment and
when you
are investing over multiple periods
and the kelly criterion tells you how to
optimally
basically bet with your bankroll and
the actually there was there's an
excellent uh
book at least i like it called fortunes
formula
that uh talks about uh what i said the
origins of
options theory and finance but it does
get into the kelly criterion and and
there was a
rather major uh discussion between
shannon a mathematician at mit who
advocated applying the kelly criteria
and paul samuelson uh one of the major
economists
also from michigan also from mit
yeah there was great dispute about how
you should do portfolio optimization
and that's a great book and a lot of
characters in that book
actually are from mit and at thorpe for
example
and it's really about i mean people try
to
find the holy grail
magic formula but not really to that
extent but finding somebody you know
something other people haven't figured
out
but uh it's very interesting history you
know big names like
you know shannon very successful in
other fields
in his later part of his career and life
really devoted
most of his time studying this problem
yeah you know shannon right so the cloud
shin
he's the he's the father of information
theory
yeah and has a lot to do with
the later you know information age
invention of computers
and very successful yeah
so anyway so we'll end the class right
here no homework for today
okay so you just need to yeah
okay all right thank you